[Music]
what's up guys I'm Andrew gold far from
gearbox today we're taking a look at the
first-ever campaign demo from battleborn
I have Aaron Lindy writer Randy Bernal
creative director Randy you know tell me
about the origins of the project we were
wrapping up Borderlands 2 I was design
producer on that project and Randy
Pitchford 9 several others got together
and were magining what do we want to do
next right and so we looked at a lot of
the things that we really really loved
about Borderlands you know making a lot
of characters coming up with a sweet
unique art style blending our favorite
games and parts of our favorite genres
together you know and doing something
new and unique and then coming up with
something that had amazing epic stakes
and embattled the word emerged out of it
it's great I didn't give you the
elevator pitch like what's the story
sure it's battle born is set in the
universe in the far far future and it's
kind of at an extreme right it's at a
time that all of the stars but one have
darkened in the sky
they've gone black and solace is the
very last star and all the other
civilizations and beings out there that
live in a vast number of planets that
darkened you know God in their spaceship
so use their forms of interstellar
travel and they traveled and they
retreated all the way back and now all
find themselves kind of here around
solace and now a meshed in a struggle
for survival and for power and for
replace they formed into these five
factions but they find out really
quickly that they're not each other's
worst enemy that the actual worst enemy
is out there the moralising this large
and dark and mysterious foe that's
coming in and has been behind the
consumption the darkening of the stars
so it's now threatening soulless itself
and so among the factions these battle
born these heroes who emerge that are
willing to set aside those differences
and bring that fight right to their LZ
to save the universe
Aaron Randy mentioned those factions I
mean we've all these different
characters kind of give me a breakdown
of how the factions work yeah sure so
like well I guess we can start off with
like the peacekeepers you know they're
the sworn protectors of Solace and do so
by enforcing a pretty heavy-handed
draconian law and you know those are
characters like Oscar Mike who is a sort
you know he's his own dude you know he's
very much his own character in Montana
you know big boisterous you know got the
minigun and all that tiny head that's
that's part of his deal we've got the
Eldred the Eldred are are their
protectors of the natural cosmological
order and that's where we have a lot of
the the fantasy tropes that were really
excited
the magic wielders and that kind of
stuff so characters like Thorin you know
she's got a really powerful bow in
addition to an array of magical
abilities as you can use moving up from
there there's a generate generate are
are sort of power-mad imperialistic
force wrath is a great pad generate
character you know you're gonna see a
lot of that heartfulness in combat and
that you know he's really into what he's
doing little bit of gone a little bit a
little bit of God does a smidge just a
smidge and from there there's the the
LLC the last light consortium there the
war profiteer is in our universe so
they're they're really interested in
arming all sides of the conflict that
they run a minion robotics make all the
robots and all the robots they sell to
all the faction exactly right yeah yeah
they're practically war profiteer
exactly purely profit driven kind of
kind of organization and yet you see a
lot of those a lot of those traits
exemplified in characters like Mark II
who you know is very much he's a very
dapper dapper fellow and lives a very
particular lifestyle that that you know
doesn't think much of the folks that you
know have less than he does and finally
there's the Rogues the Rogues are our
faction that isn't a faction you know
they've their be unaffiliated free
peoples of solar so like yeah smugglers
pirates salvagers and there's a ton of
different kinds of characters of all
shapes and sizes that fit under that you
know it's like they're just the folks
that don't fly under a banner awesome
Randy I think that's a pretty good
overview but tell us about the demo
we're about to see really excited today
is the first look at the cooperative
campaign of battle born today our battle
borns mission is to go to the planet
Tempest where there's a huge shard fall
activity a star shard these massive
sources of power and income for our
battle born is landing on the planet's
surface so a babble born are going to go
look for it they're going to be aided by
Cleese who's in the ship above flying
around kind of looking for the shards
and also ready to harvest it with a ship
also we have melka on the ground melk is
running around helping find enemies but
even more important than that just
trying to get the defense codes to the
defense system for the planet so we can
get off and we're all done so let's join
this battle born cooperative campaign
mission and progress
[Music]
so first let's take a look at some of
our battleborn today get a good
introduction starting off from the
screen here we've got Oscar Mike
can you do this do you think so alright
moving down to the group down below from
left to right one of my favorites
Montana never change my name to Montana
next to him is born again this is Miko
our combat botanist such one doc so much
wonder and last but not least Raph this
one's mine now
all right battle born let's head into
the mission will bring tempest to its
knees
easier said than done I'm afraid I've
never seen an atmosphere so active
charged hold aptly named indeed
eyes up a class-four is forming overhead
payday has landed quickly to the impact
site melka how's our exit coming I've
gained access to the tempest Defense
Grid and located the clearance codes
once I decrypt them getting off world
should be trivial way of giving you the
codes lady let me go initiating
decryption sequence uh-oh
decryption me ah I'll meet you guys at
the house at once i'm done i'm packing
the you know we've got our first mission
objective here so our battleborn are
gonna head into this first combat it was
a great chance to look at some of their
primary attacks they're very different
so we're gonna look at it from a few
different angles
D'Andrea Robo
will
all right there's a good look at the
primary attacks now let's take a look at
some of our battle born skills
ah justly angle good show
so now we've completed the objective
we've earned some experience which level
this up every time you level up in
battleborn you get to choose between
different ways to customize your
character so let's take a look at Oscar
Mike as he brings up his helix now at
level 6 we've already gotten a few
levels here at level 6
Oscar mike has a choice between red dot
sight and scope today Oscar is going to
choose red dot sight you're just going
to let him still get a great benefit to
aiming at the enemies while maintaining
his mobility
there's also a neat thing to talk about
here and that's level 7 our battle born
unlocked their ultimate skill so here's
Montana up on the ledge Montana's going
to show us his ultimate skill man's
formation Montana is a big guy moving
around slowly but man's formation gives
him a way to charge into combat and get
up close and personal so it can really
help us team out absorbing all that
damage
all right leveling up out of the way
we're going to move into the next part
of the mission now here we're going to
flip the tables a little bit and we're
going to have a defensive scenario that
shard that fell in the beginning we need
to go and help police the NPC protect it
while he harvests the shard
so battleborn are going to head out
cross the gaps where the shard is lining
up and taking these conveniently placed
jump nodes
it's battleborn let's hit the jump modes
right now
oh yeah excellent standby
sensors indicate that scores of dreadful
things are marching this way to resolve
not allow them to disrupt the harvest
sevens coach
good luck but there's more the way get
ready
wiping them out handily but this isn't
over yet
Oh coming
Wow
see again Rio no comms and senses are
offline
it appears a signal jammers be deployed
nearby destroy it
post least
neji's destroyed a lot of it extreme
prejudice
I'll see to restore communications
harvest complete we're rich and
everything is beautiful forever
muscles
[Music]
okay
[Music]
ah you lived a pleasant surprise indeed
now that the jamb is disabled I should
be able to pinpoint the last known
location ah yes here we are
be advised this place creeps the hell
out of me
quit your whining it's gonna be fine
hair not far from here
it's Milka hold on how long try to clear
up the signal
that's your first look at the
cooperative campaign for battleborn
Randy what do people see more man I'm
really excited for people to get their
hands on this game they're gonna be able
to in 2015 when it releases on Xbox one
ps4 and PC very cool Thank You Aaron
Thank You Randy thank you guys for
watching